my name's lynn wright i'm customer
service team leader
and i manage repairs and proofs i'm now
going to walk you through how our team
restores a business jacket it's an older
style jacket would don't do the strap as
much now
i think it was made in 2005
the jacket has a rip on the right side
of the front and the button needs
replaced
the jacket looks like it's dried out and
it hasn't been re-waxed for years
barber jackets all work so that they are
water resistant
over time the wax will way off so we
recommend that they are sent back to be
re-waxed every year to keep it resistant
to order
firstly i'm going to give it to one of
the operators julianne is given a job
sheet to go along with the jacket
and we'll take the old button off
we use an unpick and unpicks a little
tool that you just carefully unpick the
threads and it loosens the button off
and we'll measure the fabric out for the
size of the patch
and then we'll fold the patch and we'll
actually mark around the area where it's
ripped we cut the patch a bit bigger
about a centimeter just in case as we're
repaying the jacket it does rip more
so we'll mark it
we'll place the jacket in the machine
and we'll edge stitch the patch
where we've done the marking
the old button has a crack in it
so we're replacing it with a brand new
button
we sew that on with a hand sewn with a
needle
there's normally four holes in the
buttons who go from each corner
crisscrossing the thread
and then we'd wind the thread around the
button to secure the button
and then slip it off of our clippers
we now check for quality and we'll hang
it on the rail ready for midline
inspection
i'm going to take it over a neil and he
will relax the jacket and bring it back
to life
firstly neil i'll pick up a scoop and
fill it with hard wax from the drum
and place it into the heated pot
the wax is melted at a temperature of no
more than 60 degrees otherwise it will
be too hot and it will go through to the
lining
we remove the garment from the rail and
position it onto the table
[Music]
we will apply some fabric into the
jacket to protect the lining
he'll now zip the jacket up
and fasten any buttons or press studs on
the front of the jacket
neil is now ready to start the rewax
process which he'll use a sponge to
apply the heated wax around the parts of
the jacket using a consistent approach
[Music]
neil uses long gliding strokes for the
application of the wax that gives it a
better finish
as knee is applying the wax you'll see
that he doesn't touch the new fabric on
the repair as that's already got a lot
of wax in it
the reeboks table is also heated at 60
degrees
so the combination of the heated wax and
the heated table helps blend the wax
into the jacket to bring it back to life
as you can see neil has now done half
the jacket and you can see the
difference of when the jacket is
reproved and when it hasn't been
reproved
neil has now finished the wax on process
and will now begin the wax off process
knee will use a dry cloth to take any
excess
wax off the jacket around the seams
studs and the buttons
finally neil will unzip the jacket and
remove any fabric he's put in to protect
the lining
check the lining is clean and is in
perfect condition
when the wax process is finished we do
allow the jacket to be hung up and dried
for
anything from 30 minutes to an hour
before we dispatch
[Music]
the jacket will now be sent out to the
customer who will be very happy with the
outcome of the jacket that's been
restored repaired and rewaxed and
they'll be able to wait for years to
come on their adventures in the outdoors
[Music]
you